there's a lot of people uh that are
upset about a lot of things these days
um you know people are arguing about
whether they should get vaccinated or
not have you gotten vaccinated
yeah yeah i'm up for it too i i'm like
you know if they like dick trying to
kill me which doesn't that conspiracy i
love a conspiracy
it doesn't make any sense you don't
think the anti-vaxx
conspiracy lines up that they're that
they're gonna
that they're secretly trying to kill
each ot all of us for for population
control
no because what they would do would they
would be killing all what they call
the sheeple so all the people who be
like all the people that go what are we
supposed to do
okay they're gonna kill us right and
then just be left with all the fonzies
with their leather jackets
who are too cool to listen to people
they got a nightmare who's gonna
who's gonna dig their ditches for them
yes it just doesn't make i mean
if you wanna say that they're gonna come
up with something to thin the herd
i will go with that but they would never
do a pointed attack
on people that are going to do whatever
they say yes yes
they're eliminating the wrong group if
this is the plan so maybe they vaxxed us
sheeple so then they can have a second
vacci
of uh covid thing come out to kill all
the cool people that
hit a jukebox and it turns on
[Laughter]
so anyone who's anti-vaxx is a fonzie
that's what you're they're just all fine
look at me we have a couple of ron
howard sitting here right yeah i look
like i'm at a younger age i look at it
like i'm now
and i like to think i'm the oscar
winning director ron howard
you're still ron figuring himself i'm
still i'm towards the end of the happy
days run
i might direct the movie right around
when he started dating laurie beth
sorry that was a deep cut yeah uh okay
so the problem is in our culture now
if you have a weird belief you can find
a source that caters to that belief
and you don't have to read anything else
because the internet called the internet
yeah that's why i don't listen to
anybody's theories anymore
unless i just go did you get this
information at the
library yeah okay if you got it at the
library i'll listen to it because the
library has the decency to break up
information between non-fiction
and fiction meaning this happened and
this is just some [ __ ] people made up
you go on the internet everything is
presented
as as non-fiction and then that's why
dude in my lifetime for the i'd say for
the first 47 years
that nobody thought the earth was flat
right
and in the last five years all of a
sudden people you know are coming out
telling me there's an ice wall
that you can go look at like there's
these ice walls
like we're basically in this giant bowl
of i don't know cereal or something yeah
but then once again i'm like all right
i'll go with that but like what is the
upside
to telling me a sheeple
ron howard right that the world is flat
as round
if thing when it's really flat yeah yeah
what is the upside of doing that right
why trick us why deceive us
yeah what what do you get out of doing
that and they can't seem to answer it i
go what you need to do is get a pilot's
license
and go for your instrument rating and
then when you see vor
signals and realize one of the things
that blocks it is the curvature of the
earth
you'll stop trying to rent a boat to go
look at the nice one
you know people are flipping out about
masks and on both sides
like they're people that say uh
you know i shouldn't have to wear a mask
i don't want to wear a mask i don't buy
it and then there are people that
um i love those people what you like the
people that flip out
yeah don't wear it yeah don't wear it go
kill yourself
that's awesome cause i have to be honest
with you i know a lot of people died
from covid but i'm starting to see the
traffic come back and uh
i selfishly thought i wish it killed a
few more
i'm being honest god it's an honest
selfish
thought god that i had so just specific
commuters we've got to be clear here
people that i don't know or love
that i would never miss it's it's 100
selfish
okay you just want to know what's funny
is when i looked out there all the real
people were like this and all the
cardboard people are still
so i think overall i think it made sense
yeah kevin hart agreed with that one
yeah
all four of them no three of them went
for it one of them just
covered his face didn't want any part of
it